[Music]
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu promising to make Hamas pay
for their barbaric assault on Israel the
Israeli death toll now topping 1300 and
at least 27 Americans have been killed
Netanyahu telling the world that there's
no difference between Hamas and the most
radical Islamic terrorists Hamas is
Isis and just as Isis was crushed so too
will Hamas be
crushed and Hamas should be treated
exactly the way Isis was
treated they should be spit out from the
community of
Nations no leader should meet them no
country should Harbor them and those
that do should be sanctioned Israel
continues to hammer Hamas Targets in
Gaza with precision air strikes the
Israeli forces promising to root out
every single terrorist in response to
them butchering innocent men women and
children but but no matter what Israel
does progressives like AOC will still
accuse the country of ethnic
cleansing our
responsibility is to the stability and
the security of the region that means
being able to support uh not support yes
Israel in its defensive capacities right
in its ability in in in that context but
it also means that the United States has
a responsibility to ensure
accountability to human rights to
prevent the ethnic cleansing of
Palestinians and to ensure that Horrors
do not happen in the names of victims
who do not want their tragedy to be used
to justify further violence and
Injustice and while the likes of AOC try
to claim Israel can't respond to the
most gruesome terror attack in its
history the the country's president is
slapping down a reporter who tried to
push the same narrative
you seem to hold the people of Gaza
responsible for not trying to remove let
me finish do you hold a missile in your
kitchen in your living room can I ask my
question a missile that is sent on our
head here and if there will be a siren
it's a missile from that kitchen with
all due respect if you have a missile in
your kitchen and you want to shoot it at
me am I allowed to defend myself yes
that's the
situation well done Dana I want to go to
you first but uh permission to rant yes
okay so AOC brings up ethnic cleansing
why does she do that she's in
introducing a rhetorical uh a rhetorical
method to prevent Israel from Seeking
Justice from their tormentors again it's
enabling the free punch from the
perpetrators while applying the stain of
the oppressor on the victim I would like
to know from AOC what the proportionate
response should be maybe she could draw
up a handy chart when Hamas does X you
do 1% of X I think that would be really
really helpful you know when they behead
your children you can write an angry
letter to the local paper what do you
think and you can March down to the
boss's office and complain put a little
letter in the recommendations box uh a
couple things well she talks about
ethnic cleansing well what do you think
Hamas is doing Hamas literally wants the
extinction of the Jewish State that's
their Charter that is actually the
definition of ethnic cleansing also for
the reporter that was asking president
Herzog those questions try doing that in
Iran yeah or to Hamas or to the
Egyptians or and speaking of the
Egyptians why isn't anybody in the Arab
world willing to take the Gins who are
being told to get out so that they can
have safety who cares about them oh what
about Hamas does Hamas care about them
Hamas has not done anything with the
money that they've been given to provide
electricity or water why is that Israel
responsibility I don't think that is
necessary the other thing is the
thinking is so a terrorist kills a baby
mhm and in response to that you try to
kill the terrorist but he's holding his
baby yes in front of him as a human
shield so the study of the the laws of
war would be helpful from some of these
reporters because Israel is literally
fighting for its very existence its
invulnerability was shattered and they
are going to need the space and time
just think about it we are 6 days from
babies being beheaded and already you
have the press and Democrats and
Academia saying oh gosh maybe we really
should oh yeah please like let's back
off yeah yeah the narrative I could
think of something else that ends in off
but I will not say it good for you Dana
we'll save it for the break bill you
spent a lot of time in Israel in the
Middle East it feels like this happens
over and over again where they exploit
this David versus Goliath myth that
somehow uh terrorists are David because
they're not a nation state right and so
then but they can operate independent of
any moral Norms which actually makes
them Goliath we woke up this morning to
Benjamin Netanyahu giving what I thought
was a pretty stunning press conference
it was 6 o'clock in the morning Anthony
blinkin was there US Secretary of State
and what Netanyahu said is that Hamas is
Isis all right and Hamas must be
eliminated um I don't know if Israel can
do that
you know we we we took out uh raqqa in
eastern Syria and claimed victory over
Isis but Isis still exists today um I
I'm not sure Israel can do this job I'm
not sure we can do this job um but
Anthony blinkin also stepped to the
microphone with Netanyahu this morning
and he said I am
Jewish and let me tell you about my
grandparents who fled Russia former
Soviet Union during the second world war
let me tell you about my grandparents
who surviv the concentration camps it
was a very powerful message I thought it
was Anthony blinken's strongest moment
that we have seen as a public servant
for our country um he then went on late
today to Aman Jordan he's going to go to
the UAE cter Saudi Arabia and Egypt now
we know in a big picture scene that a
lot of these leaders want this region to
excel
economically and they know they cannot
convince
International businesses to do business
with them if you
have Fanatics like Hamas underneath the
service who who lie and wait for a
period of six years and make you think
that they want peace with
you what we don't know is beneath the
surface in these other
countries I don't think the United
States I don't think Israel can wipe
this out I think you need a regional
effort coordinated
with public statements of will backed by
a military response to try and get some
progress here the other thing I would
add is we really don't know where we are
in this war as of tonight you say day
six Dana uh correct on that um but what
happens next does Hezbollah act up in
the north we don't know does Iran pull
another shoot and get more action within
Israel don't know you know there turmoil
within the West Bank and has been for
weeks um I I I don't know what the
second chapter is in the story and I
don't and no one knows how much longer
this war will last you know judge he uh
Bill brings up this coordinated idea of
a coordinated effort we've had 27
Americans killed there'll probably be
more we've waged War for Less is it time
to consider you know what we do never
mind the quote
escalation you know Greg that was
exactly where I was going but before I
get there I want to make one comment
about AOC AOC to talk about ethnic
cleansing in relation to you know
Palestine the Jews from the beginning of
time have been the subject and the
target of ethnic cleansing I mean we
don't have to go through history to know
that that's their target and as you say
that's the mission and I also want to
say one thing about AOC you know she's a
political ideologue what she said is
says is Small Potatoes this is a bigger
issue but in 2021 when Congress
allocated money for more interceptors
for the Iron Dome who was crying in
Congress at the time she said I wept at
the complete lack of care for human
beings being impacted by these decisions
wept over the fact that Israel had an
Iron Dome where they could defend
innocent Israelis put that aside let's
talk about the fact that the Arab world
is not accepting these Palestinians all
right Egypt is not accepting AC ing them
the Arab world from the creation of the
of the state of Israel the nation state
in 1948 wanted no part of the
Palestinians what does that tell you and
Hamas does not take their power or their
their whatever leverage they have with
Iran or the other Arab countries to say
you know what take in these Palestinians
why because they want to use them as
leverage they want to use them to be
able to say to the world look Israel is
killing these Palestinians all right who
by the way have been given notice we
going to take out Gaza at this point now
to the final question there was a
question asked today of Kirby 27
Americans were killed that's a very
large number larger than the number of
Americans killed by terrorists during
the withdrawal from Afghanistan larger
than the number of Americans killed at
the USS Cole larger than those killed in
Bazi or beheaded by ISIS and 27
Americans killed why is it the posture
of the Biden Administration to just let
Israel handle this job instead of US
forces going in and getting the guys
that not only killed Americans but that
are holding them hostage and I know
people I spoke to a doctor friend of
mine who on Sunday was flying in people
to Israel I mean it's the private sector
again the former government sector or
people who were in the government who
were taking this on Harold that's a good
question welcome back to the table uh
feel free to uh talk about anything
regarding this issue since you haven't
been here for three days a couple things
and I'm glad to be back um as it relates
to the congresswoman from New York uh I
think you've all said it well she talked
about the framework that the US is
committed to uh ensuring the stability
and security of the region I can think
of no other way no bigger way to secure
or to stabilize the region than to do
what the Israelis and the Americans are
committed to doing which is to
eliminating the ter terrorist
capabilities and infrastructure of Hamas
uh the Congress uh those in Congress
please get a speaker if it takes
Democrats to do it we need it to ensure
that we can provide whatever support is
needed but I would say to those
Democrats who are dealing with some
Democrats who are saying things that I
think uh are against the notion of
providing a framework for security and
stability in the Middle East ignore them
and get on with the business of ensuring
that America can support Israel in all
that it needs to do too I hope that NBS
and Mr Netanyahu do not allow this awful
tragic um set of events or incident uh
to prevent them from going forward with
their plan to chart a new course in
future for freedom and Reconciliation
and shared growth in the region this is
one of the reasons why I believe this
attack happened and I'm hopeful that you
guys won't let that go in fact uh the
congresswoman and others who are being
critical in some ways of Israel this is
why it happened because Israel and NBS
were trying to provide a new framework a
sturdier framework work for stability
and Security in the region finally I I
I'm going to give the the the White
House some benefit of the doubt here I
do think first they should say we're
freezing the funds the six billion that
cutter are working on say you're
freezing it uh because if that's what
we're doing America and the world needs
to know that two judge you're right if
we need to send more planes to help
people evacuate we should but I don't
think the White House should disclose
all of their operational plans we
certainly don't want to give that to
those who may be opposed to us or for
that matter opposed to America
and we know who some may be in that
region uh I'm glad to be able to speak
on this I've been I've been proud to
watch this group around this table over
the last several days um this has been a
Unity that I think the country wants
even though there are few voices out
there that uh in my party and perhaps
some in the other party uh that I think
don't speak for what's Best in America's
interest or for that matter the Region's
interest well said hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most comp in analysis you
will not get it anywhere
else